welcome to this video for round five of
the chess olympiad in istanbul um yeah
we had two very heavy weight clashes
yesterday between Ukraine and amenia
which ended in a victory for for the
minyan team and Russia played against
them Hungary which is also very strong
team and here the Russian team won so
after five rounds they're only young two
teams left with a perfect score from ten
ten points this is amenia Russia and
those two teams will play on monday the
6th round and obviously the sum is very
important for them overall standings as
some if this match should have them yeah
winner then they already would have
quite a nice not a substantial but quite
a nice lead in the tournament but let's
check on what happened yesterday in the
iminium on Ukraine match here we had at
the end three drawers and the match on
board one between levon aronian and
tongue Vasily valchek proved to be the
decisive game of this match let's have
look I'm aronian up to now um had a very
nice tournament until now and if one
shockley I had a shaky start but then
recovered a bit with a victory against
what r shake I showed this briefly in
the video of yesterday's alright so
let's see what happens aronian starts
off with nida 390 64 e 6 and now d for
returning to young normal d for openings
aronian is the default player mostly but
sometimes he varies with nida 30 c form
the one shall place the Queen's Indian
defense on it one show get some yeah the
world's most versatile player can
basically
play any any opening so um that wasn't I
guess possible in any way to guess what
what happened on so Ronan played g3
which he usually does I thank push of a
six and now be three that the
traditional main line why's of course
has alternatives but let's not get into
this too too deeply so Bishop a 67 is a
move designed to provoke some kind of
weakness from wide end this b3 move has
weakened some squares lots of our black
gown can give the check here and wide
play Bishop T 292 is it's not good in
show briefly while there are these kinds
of her ideas and then that's quite funny
um all right if not not again not an
honor with those players so Bishop e2
and Bishop e7 so black has lost the
temple here to to put the bishop from
wide them on the square way at them yet
doesn't sit so comfortably would rather
prefer to have the bishop on me too okay
93 developing the piece and now be
should be seven bag at this Bishop
didn't have much much to do anymore c4
was nicely protected there are
alternatives really in this opening and
about every move that is according to
the rules of chess and has been played
Bishop g2 castles castles and also here
black has alternatives he can play 55
for example or maybe even this move I
don't know this not the most logical one
maybe but then there are possibilities
he played 9 a-6 which is also may move
and him aronia actually am play dumb
rather rare move to my surprise when I
was watching this this game I thought
okay this is seven
natural this idea but it hasn't been
played in this particular position maybe
form or has been played but only in
three or four games this is the move d5
get this typical advance um which is
also very well known in another similar
Queens Indian lines the idea is to
establish a pawn on d5 and this way
obstructing at the b7 Bishop of course
some people I can just take it and now
we've got to see that this is actually a
temporarily a temporary and pawn
sacrifice and why it needs to make use
of this diagonal so it plays Knight to
g4 um just capturing gives away the pawn
for pretty much nothing so it is 94 now
we see this diagonal builds up a pin and
wide threatens to just take you and it's
really a threat this kind of structure
let's say black would play a nothing
move like this this kind of structure
would be am very uncomfortable for black
as this Bishop is just them very bad
piece possibly also the Seaport can be
an issue it's not nice at all so if one
should played this move Bishop c5 very
concrete attacking on the night which
can which retreated to to see two and we
see that um this light also has a route
oops nope this was a bit too much here
on d5 wants to go on d5 um yeah black
now played c6 he doesn't really have fun
I think anything else otherwise why
would just capture on d5 and has a very
comfortable position here he is at least
a pawn up for the moment yeah I'm
Carolyn plays Bishop g5 or kassam he
wants to increase the pressure on the t5
porn and with this pin
actually threatens to to take it so
Yvonne Chaka covered it again and now 93
is very very logical natural kind of
development here why put some the
Admirals pressure on the d5 pawn and
tries to regain it and black gum tries
to defend it with all on his pieces here
he M plate I think already a serious
serious mistake but then at wheels I
don't like black positions so much
anyway but this is our thing a narrow as
it turns out them in the game you played
defo a radical kind of solution to to
the Sun to this position then the issue
is in general if you just look at this
what would happen if black play some
nothing move yeah like let's say let's
say rookie ATM just just for argument's
sake um then what would play something
like this like this takes on d5 and have
all kinds of threats now also so on
there's not much choice like basically
needs to take this again and we again
threaten this year so this kind of
position would would arise say look
movies one was hanging and you clear and
this is just a very uncomfortable
position for black white is got the two
bishops and even if he at one point is
forced to take on f6 let's say black
plays here and you know take oops I need
to switch that up and now this this kind
of position is just done very
uncomfortable for back to play this
Bishop is just much stronger than the c5
Bishop the c5 Bishop just looks at this
pawn chain and this doesn't do any
while at seven of this is a real serious
pressure for example this kind of IDM
could be possible or any kind of work
left on the fourth-ranked so on while
black gun still is fairly solid it's
absolutely no fun to play this this is I
think also why I went from this defines
an alternative though was to take on III
which is also kind of ugly but them it's
an idea here what actually has a choice
he can just recapture with the with the
bishop and trying to play young
strategically again this d5 pawn get it
back and some point and then try to have
this kind of positional advantage
compared to a similar to the line i just
showed with rupee aid you can also maybe
this is stronger take with the pawn this
is the the dynamic choice putting
pressure on the update at six light on
this isn't done particularly clear let's
say something like this takes hear this
kind of position yeah check this a bit
with with the engine and computer
actually think this is around equal as I
mean this is really a computer computer
assessment i think a human group
wouldn't like to play l'exposition much
it's got this summer wheat king bed
bishop I don't know maybe it's
technically okay for black but it's also
not much fun still compared to the game
I think this was preferable this D
formal firm turns out yeah I'm not to be
working really took on b7 of course this
was just hanging and the rupee a this
was the IDM like sacrifice this Bishop
home move and now there are three M
pieces hanging so on he will get
something back that's not the problem
the problem is
that white has the move from light
reform and now in South reddening on on
f6 and black now doesn't have much
choice he needs to get the piece back he
took on on c3 at the end if you look at
the alternative rook takes be seven then
there's this cute move 94 and now that's
really a thing the utmost pressure on
the night you really don't see this too
often and what should like do now it's
um it's really a really awful something
like this we can easily imagine this
child of position coming up and here
this is some yeah it's just very ugly
why can play all kinds of Lucia um you
can bring a light to f5 but they're also
very a direct ideas even this movements
an idea the idea being that this really
am gets to the f6 porn and also possibly
this kind of ideas to look and this this
is a quite dangerous route to h5 queen
bee three and h7s son pretty much gone
so um yeah very ugly so he was right to
take on c3 this is in comparison the
much better defense sub you should now
take some 6g tags and we should be four
and now we see the kind of position that
what was aiming for his got them yeah he
sacrifice a pawn for this position but
you see that those are two really great
pieces and also there's the Sun optional
idea Bishop back m23 and age seven sm
yeah are too hard to cover in the game
one should play t5 which i think is
correct in eastern get something going
here Bishop to see two and now f5 and
this is also a good move he realized
that it's better to give up one of those
two pawns and in order to to to get the
Queen
to play you see what happens what kids
to check and takes now and now Queen to
a 6 which at least activates likes
pieces a bit this double pawn was
ruffles anyway yeah and now on white um
played a really a really excellent move
and this is the MOOC a 3-wood gem the
first side looks a bit mysterious but
the idea is he wants to play B form and
provoke a move of the bishop back from
this diagonal then also see free would
be much weaker and ya black ass am
basically forced to prevent this be
formless and now cuide you through your
shell yeah just lines up against h7 and
threatening possible discoveries
anywhere yeah it's not mop nice to play
this position in fact on him a bunch o
gum yeah premium made the decisive
mistake but it's am very hard to run to
play this position and also very
difficult to spot what what's coming up
played with Jade in fact what he should
have played his rook e8 anticipating
this before idea end the game obviously
this position so yeah it's terrible to
play for black white can play all kinds
of moves before it's still an idea also
you could prepare it or just play a
normal position and move like III after
black gum yeah like simply yet doesn't
have any any fun in this position is on
the constant pressure yeah but in the
game as mentioned if a group g8 yeah and
now it happens before very strong move
like it doesn't have much choice he
needs to to grab this and after this I
mean okay he could have played the
passive move
Bishop here to cover all those Nigel
squares but what what is this also not
nice one very important point is always
this move threatening made and gave the
porn back I mean it's just it's just
ugly so it took on before I think this
is under the circumstances the radishes
decision and lupe seven now just text
the night yep right here and now this
cute move 97 this was yeah in the air
for a while threatening a queen to age
seven checkmate and this book is hanging
Plus this is an idea n96 oh there's a
ton of Forbes now and lack will loose
material we played Queen g7 and here why
does even spoiled her choice he could
also play a night here but he just took
the took the rook just perfectly ok and
now this pawn yeah white now is some
kleenex changeup and still has the far
better position the only thing it needs
to be sure about is that those pawns
don't get any dangerous but this Bishop
is just a grape he is covering with some
he have the C 2 square so that the C
porn cannot advance further yeah why
does winning but it's still a matter of
the airplane precisely to win it 12 play
down Bishop c5 and now we've got III
important move taking away a square and
also shielding the King d5 and now okay
eight getting rid of this active rupees
helpful text takes Queen f8 yeah and now
on I think it's important not to
exchange Queens you still have this dis
attacking ideas so we went to before not
exchanging the Queen's
in here cavion this pawn and now okay
one itches yeah quite obvious you want
to activate your pieces so um like now
plate reform which is so okay you cannot
do much really Group A five pressurizing
the serve this Bishop move back and now
Queen g4 check in here and Queen h4
still having this meeting ID on H them
but also intending rook here so that
black will be tied down on the 8th
ranked as well so h6o gate and 97 yeah
here White had more than one way to to
win this game he decided them on the
most direct way you could also play
simply this move let's say large him and
then why just captures salt so very
simple but he chose to just capture here
which is via in a way the easiest
easiest move one should cook with the
Queen if you look at them committed King
takes also then white can just do the
check here and get the my turn back yeah
in the game it was a similar to check
here to go here and Queenie fun again
this this mating idea and yeah now there
are some vino moves and black girls here
you win this night oops also check of
course and yeah this move you have got
another check and the night falls so on
in fact them yeah even shook after Queen
a fiver resigned the game so on yeah
very nice effort from from
Ian who um hate this enterprising idea
of d5 which is not it on you in this
some type of position but somehow
Carlton even shocked wrong-footed and
they didn't defended yes so stubbornly
after being surprised in the opening and
the very nice I think technical display
how to how to win this position here by
11 yeah this was a very important game
obviously as amenia still keeps the
perfect score one hundred percent five
wins and Ukraine lost their first
measure so they need to yeah get back
into the hunt after this loss yeah i'm
also going to present you on a second
game today and this is from the from the
women's section and one game called no I
because of the surprising result but
also because of yeah what happened in
the game I need to pull it up here in
just a second we to upload it from from
outside just secondly you till we find
it I hope this is right sorry cannot you
know how to prevent this if I load this
okay so um this is the game from the
from the women's section has mentioned
um between I'm okay we got the wrong
wrong ratings again between layfon when
and another tomski wit nami against um
the USA and also let me know who just do
something here just a second I need to
to pull up my my analysis also my I
prepared analysis alright so now I'm
ready ok so in this game the Vietnamese
play
she played 1d4 and that one skid plate
d5 okay the real ratings by the way am I
macerated about 2,500 2,500 12 and later
when is so to 393 so slightly below 2500
so gap blacks a favorite in this game
but it's not done not such a huge
difference okay be 45 and now you should
be for the London system yeah very often
um this opening has the reputation of
being rather rather dull but them I
think especially in this move or after
d4 d5 Bishop f4 it's something you can
really consider at least for surprise
value I mean in the Queens gambit why
doesn't have much anyway and this has
got some some interesting ideas and yeah
one of them we would see in the game so
the times we played Knight f6 III and e6
so the very cons conservative way to
play this is black of course some black
has got options and a puzzle piece know
that the times are bogus yeah ok so we
six black has other ideas of course like
and play like like this on sloth fashion
and the white just continues with c4 for
instance in this position and intense a
kind of normal development you don't
need to play with xiii all the time
which is sometimes you be passive ok so
what baptized I don't sleep lately six
you should be 3c 5c 396 murder 3 are
very normal there should be six ER main
alternative for black years we should be
seven which is also fine she played you
should be six though we should be three
wide wants to keep the bishop and yeah
well like what would take now you've got
the th farm as a possible possible way
of generating play so she cancelled very
long [ __ ] 192
and the Queen seven all this makes a
very good natural impression the idea
now is of course play be five so if
white wood let's say castle here like
simply plays be 50 ft one take for us
also but same another five and term yeah
black would affirm equalized easily
especially as she has gotten this this
Bishop out now this is no problem
anymore so in this position black
actually threatened the smooth and white
currently placed 95 placing a piece of
the file so that black hand out to play
this liberating move yeah he have like
played the completely normal looking 97
increasing the pressure yeah and white
now blade Knight takes these heaven
which looks perfectly normal maybe also
a DM would have been of course a form
but 97 is fine and this actually set
them an absolutely amazing um sequence
of moves in motion like now played the
perfectly normally move Bishop takes
discipline I would I would think that
she played this and let's say five
seconds or 10 seconds because it's the
most non within the world in fact this
move is a serious mistake but then it's
absolutely I think impossible to see at
the board if you don't know what's
what's happening now because in fact
this innocent-looking position has got a
devilish detective and I'll show
afterwards why Quint XD seven is the
move that this gas-saving blood here
Bishop d7 and now I play the following
Bishop d6 Queen B 6 t takes d5 and and
now you really think what the heck is
going on what is why doing why is she
giving up the center Queen takes e5 and
now why it has the amazing move
Bishop takes h7 checking the h7
sacrifice in this position is really one
of the most amazing sequence of moves
that I that I ever saw I mean the fun
thing is all this has already happened
about 10 times before I found like 10
games in the database I also knew this
idea and saw this in a book once and
it's has been played like 10 times
already black players tend to step into
this because the moves are perfectly
normal and another tone ski here with
2,500 rating which is not even the the
highest rated player yeah who fell for
this I mean it's really amazing this
kind of move a shock let's let's let's
look at them at the idea because at
first you might think this is complete
nonsense yeah black of course needs to
take it teen aged five check so far so
good Kim here and now 94 and this is the
big trick winning a tempo on the Queen
because of this year and yeah like I'm
needs to move the Queen the fun thing is
at first you might think all right okay
i can play g6 and win a tempo here but
this is not working at all because of
the simple capture attack the rogue and
now let's set gives hear it at the end
was given as two extra points and this
line is exactly the reason why you need
to recapture with the Queen if you go
back and look at all this here like we
captured with the Queen and we do the
exact same thing then black has this
move g6 because after this yeah there's
no piece hanging on d7 then the other
position white can take on d7 black has
an extra move but not I had not I have
for 1k Black is just a piece
and winning so I'm really amazing okay
let's let's go to this position a temp
oh yeah black can cause needs to move
the Queen and she went for you five
which is I think of the relative passed
and now NAT G 5pm yeah it's not exactly
a sock Lau the IDM and the whole point
of all this is she played now rupee
eight but you can also look at this move
which covers h7 Hawaii even has before
it's an incredibly incredibly deep
concept which is it is amazingly working
for wide and get this is in fact I think
completely completely losing black gum
doesn't even have a way to continue the
fight iam so Queen d3 is not working she
went for um rookie aid and in former
games they also had been played the room
d 8 this is her not know this is quite a
good at the end I think compared to
obviate mean what I would like to to
help us the clock times on this game
because it's obvious that the white
player she she knew what she was doing
especially considering that one of the
first games where this was played this
was played by a male in with Hermes
player against the Grandmaster and in
fact in the Chess Olympiad on him two
years ago so it's very likely that she
knew all this enter maybe had done some
preparation going even for the stem yeah
rupee Aiden I was played and I would
like to know how much time the tongs key
had spent up to now because I'm very
sure that she had spent them really in
huge amounts of time to even to figure
this out and to recover from the shock
because I think if someone takes on h7
on you and I would be completely shocked
I know I am absolutely sure okay so
rookie aid yeah black needed turn to to
get some space for the King so rupee aid
and why captured king
here and now she played rugby one yeah I
think here White had had the better move
actually but then it said it's obviously
I'm not not easy at all and I think them
the best continuation would have been
Queen g6 in this position but it's very
complicated Queen g6 Kim g8 and now
actually long castles too young to
protect me to and maybe continue in this
fashion pushing the edge phone it's very
difficult for black to defend against
this and for example if black now we'll
play our routines let's say here then
then H form is the point advancing the
porn or getting this kind of idea into
play this is some I think very good for
white don't think that leg would be and
be able to hold this position but before
you look at this of course we need to
check what would actually happen if
wives would grab this bishop this is of
course just hanging at first sight but
in fact this is the point of this rope
yet move black can take on be to winning
a tempo and something like this is
actually very similar to the game and
this is still better for white no doubt
about it but it's not winning instantly
I actually think that if she would have
played Queen g6 this would have been
over in a couple of moves I learnt in
black and hold this at all the game has
mentioned it was rookie one like took
castles who will see three and twenty
seven so this is very similar as I
mentioned to the line that i showed
before just look on d1 and yeah let's
take stock here like how to return the
piece and intact from a material point
of view it's equal the only issue but
it's an important issue is blacks King
she still has got this week king and
white will will get some playing
slips no doubt about it and especially
considering that most likely she didn't
have much time and this position is
really very uncomfortable to play let's
look what happened Queen f6 and queen
returns yeah the King steps out of these
checks and f4 of course wyd wants to use
the look probably here on to h3 and also
maybe play at five at some point very
logical move rookie eight Andrew p.m.
yeah and in this position it's moved 24
and I bet that leg didn't have much time
on the clock and yeah she break she
broke down in this position I think
black needs to play some Jam some
waiting with them then say a 60 not not
change the position at all what she
played this I'm sorry g6 okay Queenie
ch4 and now she needs to play the
waiting move um you should let me five I
got confused sorry I'm now she played e5
instead she I think shouldn't move
anything significant at all something
like this for for example um it's not a
helpful move but you cannot do much
white still has this attack and these
are things anyway pretty much better but
if I've is just losing using the frost
and snow is why it took 25 and now Roe
care for me and this is very strong
because wide 70 threatens night f 79 h6
or look at seven various attacking ideas
on f7 and black has no way to prevent
any of this should play dumb rupee eight
and now we mentioned like f7 idea yeah
we're should let go it's just um just a
terrible position she went here cakes
yeah you can exchange Queens it's a no
big deal Group chief who check
and now King at seven only move of
course them you go go here does this one
with made next move Kim here and now
just move just threatening checkmate
yeah and black I'm black doesn't have
any defense she played rupee six
probably with nothing on the clock and
resigned after this losing the rook yeah
the main reason why i want to show this
game is the amazing Bishop sacrifice on
h7 I think this is really one of the
most remarkable things that the diet
that I know in terms of early tactics in
the opening because white when he loses
time in a way with taking taking again
giving up the center and so this is
jacking yeah this is just them yeah a
matter of concrete tactics being much
more important than any em than any
general considerations you would think
that this is all good we're good white
is doing but this move is working and
probably winning even yet has caught a
many strong players by surprise and yeah
claimed another victim here and the
victim here and there women section of
the Olympiad yeah I hope you enjoyed
both games and I'll continue coverage on
yeah I need to think about this on
Monday that's the next round and don't
you stay i'm traveling back at home from
my vacation and i'm not sure if i can
make a video maybe in the evening but
after nine hours of of train rides and
flying and so on i'm not sure but i'll
do them i do more unlimited coverage for
sure i'm not quite sure and what on what
day exactly yeah sure send have a good
sunday